starting with the newest addition one of
the newest additions anyway Yousef
Gatewood the new regions of New Orleans
Danielle Campbell as Davina the
unofficial Mikaelson brother Charles
Michael Davis
[Applause]
actually allotted extra time for
screaming so honestly just go for it
creator and executive producer Julie
Plec the man who will break your heart
and then rip it out and probably eat it
Joseph Morgan
[Applause]
the brother with a suit for every
occasion Daniel Gillies
[Applause]
my second yeah give it up for this
jacket out of a suit and into a
smoking-hot jacket I'm not right though
one time it's not where to sit these
she-wolf who is currently more wolf than
she if Phoebe Tonkin executive producer
Michael neurosis and everybody's
favorite token human Lea pipes the
season that we all enjoyed but I think I
really need to address something that we
just saw in that video which was new I
believe Julie and Michael who the hell
are those two people and how can we make
them dead they actually you know it was
a scene that we shot for the season
finale at the end of last year we wanted
to kind of have a little tag at the very
end that said oh there's danger coming
in a new form and then when we saw the
episode we preferred it ending on
classes emotional moment I'm sort of
just teeing up that there were new
enemies to come and then when we hadn't
started shooting this year yet and we
you know you love to come to comic-con
and show off new footage but we didn't
have any and so we thought how can we
show the audience like what is in the
works and we thought oh there's that
scene so we used it and it's just a hint
of their duty it's a little hint of
what's to come in terms of the new
villains meaning we talked a lot about
how the mikaelsons have been around for
a thousand years and somewhere along the
way they've probably turned a bunch of
people into vampires and those vampires
know that if an original dies as we saw
with Finn and we saw with Cole an entire
sire line will be wiped out so what
perspective do those tired vampires have
all of them the remaining three sire
lines what do they think about the
continued existence of the Mikaelson
family so that's that's the seed for
season three
very cool does that mean that the the
Dahlia Esther all of that is kind of
that chapter is now closed we're kind of
not focusing on the parents anymore
well the beauty of it is is that the the
mikaelsons were able to vanquish their
parents and their evil nasty aunties and
and so now they get to experience what
it's like to be this so-called parent
themselves of their of their first line
of sired vampires and so the children
are coming to town with with an axe to
grind well now I know you guys have not
gone into you've like started a little
bit but your haven't gone into
full-fledged production on the new
season with everybody you know filming
is this what you guys have like a
tradition when you all go back to
Atlanta to film I'm thinking like
karaoke some kind of bonding thing
Joseph is in charge of story selectivity
all right so I organized a gathering
that was swiftly followed by Phoebe
Tonkin inviting us and then canceling
the day off I was invited to a party
with Daniel Gillies and Scott Baio and
then you didn't show I could cancel that
last night unfortunately a child was in
charge Scott Baio who of course will be
a vampire in season three now we're
going to the show we've seen Klaus and
Hayley kind of trying the the
co-parenting thing it did not really go
so well as we all saw how is farce gonna
kind of be as as a parent without
without Hayley around well you know
before he alienated his entire family of
toasting lightest girlfriend and and and
and cursing the woman who's in love with
clouds survived sort of under the
umbrella of Elijah's protection and
forgiveness I suppose and so Elijah was
always a voice of reason and Hayley was
always there to battle it out with him
so I would say badly he's he's gonna do
badly as a single parent you know and I
think he knows he's kind of messing it
up but he's trying at least he's trying
you gotta give him that
even if he's warping the mind of his
young daughter before she's absent even
a syllable well I imagine he can always
compel you know a few dozen manis but he
does have a larger there to kind of help
them co-parents I'm thinking like shared
schedules midnight feedings who's doing
what it's like we both wake up when the
baby's crying
remember to Freya is going to be doing
the line cheer come on praise praise
Richland at this moment I think for both
of us to be in there it's just I'm gonna
stop talking
[Laughter]
speaking of Freya you know I think Riley
is a great addition to the show you know
it's it's it's got to be kind of tough
coming into such a tumultuous family and
kind of finding her way so how how is
that character kind of gonna fit in
season three and how is Riley fitting in
with you guys
I think Riley owned it I mean she felt
to me like a Mikaelson right from the
beginning very strong very intense and
you know 25 percent batshit insane and
very very great addition to the family I
think Klaus made a calculated decision
when Dahlia told him that she would be
needed to raise this child because she
was a firstborn Mikaelson witch and
without Dahlia hope might go a little
bit off-course and classic no there's no
way I'm gonna let my baby be taken by
this witch so he made sure that she was
taken down and then invited and made
peace with his sister and brought her
into the family so she has a very
important part to play in this family
and and I think Daniel is absolutely
right the brothers are estranged but
Freya who has wanted a family for a
thousand years is coming into that
compound and she's gonna live there and
she wants for there to be peace in the
family and they're gonna need to find
some way to deal with one another given
what's coming well I think anytime you
bring somebody in under the umbrella of
the Mikaelson family
or even really within the cast of stuff
you know you're always sort of like
how's this gonna work and there's a
person gonna be you know are they gonna
fit in and what's beautiful about Riley
is that she just is one of those great
personalities and but you know wonderful
spirits that she's kind of dropped right
in and and made herself at home and and
we wished actually she was here she's in
Atlanta with her mom yeah it clicked
right from the beginning you know when
when we first did the scene with her she
walked right between Klaus and Elijah in
the graveyard and kind of threatened us
both brothers both in our places to like
okay she can she can I wanted her off
the set I said get her out of here he
said let's get her out I think is
extremely threatened by this actress but
you know despite his playtests we kept
her and then you know she she told the
story of her childhood with Dalia and so
then we got to see a little emotional
side from prayer and she rocked that as
well and so I think at that point
everyone was like hey can she stay I
think we should only talk about France
about France
well actually I mean I have to go back
to Klaus and Hayley for a minute I feel
like I've always viewed them as sort of
like a like a really bitter divorced
couple and they have to share this child
I'm kind of wondering if they were to go
in front of like a judge like
supernatural Judge Judy let's say and
and argue their case for custody who do
you think would would get that baby well
firstly I think it would probably be
Jerry Springer if they were gonna get
custody it's not the question I probably
Haley you're awful
[Laughter]
as a mini heart attack I mean I don't
know what to say tonight because she's
got a point
although I will say that I think Hayley
you know it's a whole life she's wanted
family and she never had parents of her
own so I think no matter how bad causes
the Hayley she's still gonna want to
create a kind of normal family dynamic
for her daughter so she always will want
hope to have a mom and dies so they're
gonna have to at least be in the same
room together I think yeah I think the
struggle is what
um benefit hope ultimately because each
of them believes they're doing the right
thing for her and and they've you know
especially while Klaus believes he do
for the greater good he's doing all
these terrible things to protect his
daughter but I think while Hayley was
still in human form and able to argue
with him there was a nice struggle and
out of that struggle came the decisions
how to raise the door
their daughter that you know there is in
fact a custody fight very early on in
the season that very violent but does
result in in in a decision on who should
really be in possession and taking care
of that baby so it's funny you should
ask there oh now it's a good thing we
have cami around because I feel like
this baby when she grows up is gonna
need so much therapy like like you would
not believe do you are you prepared for
any prepared they're gonna sit sit grown
up hope down and really explain what's
going on well I think still have an
advantage having such a complicated
relationship with hopes father something
like I know where all of this is coming
from trust me
but yeah cabbie has her degree now she's
that her first client is is Klaus which
I feel like if she can solve that
problem so you can pretty much solve any
problem anyone's problem so yeah I think
he's a little conflict of interest thing
there but well well let it go
and that's it I was kind of hoping that
we would have like a highchair at the
end of this table for at least one of
the babies a little maybe like a little
microphone who kind of works best with
with the babies on set I work with them
so much they're so cute the twins ever I
knew that but yeah there's two babies
two baby hopes and occasion the other
babies and agree that when they one
minute when those two babies are on
another movie and we have and then
Chucky yeah the most terrifying face
frightening rubberband
we have we have like the American the
hyper baby in me it's not an inexpensive
it's a baby like I wish you name the
price take schooi but it's a very very
expensive it's like little foot will
dangle out of the bunting of the
wrapping I'm gonna be like gives me
nightmares just thinking about it
on the flip side I feel like hope is
maybe one of the cutest babies I have
ever seen on television
yeah that goes for all of the hopes was
like the casting process like that were
you like no not this baby no yes
rejection starts early actually the
original am i mistaken the baby hope and
the funeral dream sequence was actually
the child of our craft service guy right
who was it had a basically a four month
old and said hey you know when I look at
my kid and then you can't say no to the
craft service guy yeah he's so awkward
magnifica child's not good enough but
but she was beautiful and and then then
it was just about yes well then you know
no one should put a child into acting
that was a picture like cute baby
pictures there's actually like the best
often unit work ever they've had this
room and there was like six sets of
twins and it was just like and Phoebe
and I went back there and like you hold
all of you yeah like exploding ovaries
like some of you aren't gonna be here
yeah
now I know that Haley is not gonna be
around necessarily all the time to be
with hope but you can confirm that she
will we will see Phoebe Tonkin in the
flesh yes have you I know you guys you
guys haven't started shooting it have
you all seen like the first scripts
three I want four soon Prezi so you do
know you're just being cagey yeah of
course
who's gonna kind of lead the charge in
in getting getting Haley back I mean I
feel like it should be Eliza but I don't
know
oh it's it's Elijah you know he's gonna
be holding a lot more coats out in the
wilderness the coats are going to become
exponentially smaller not even a false
moustache
[Laughter]
what can you gonna say about that
relationship because you know I know you
know Haley is a married woman and I do
believe in the sanctity of you know
werewolf hybrid unions but obviously
there is still something there between
Haley and Elijah so what are your kind
of thoughts on that I mean you know one
thing I can say about Elijah is that he
has monumental patience I think hey
he'll just wait it out he'll wait for
Jackson to die no I
he's always gonna be there for her when
you know when she needs him I think but
all those patients that Klaus has run
out
well that's it's a thousand years of it
he's only had like
that's a Groupon I think I think he's
he's gonna remain devoted to her through
whatever we didn't move on that was
beautiful
going back to what cami for a little bit
she and clouds shared some some pretty
interesting words in that finale hinting
at maybe a really strong connection
between them sort of stole maid
situation what is it about her and his
connection that kind of really gets him
to really open up because he's kind of a
cage again yeah I think you know we were
just talking about this today actually
and Narducci was wonderful enough to
explain to me like what's going on with
my character which sometimes I need but
um I think Steve she saw her brother go
into such darkness and it twin brother
who's a mirror of her so it was you know
a very dark experience for her and she's
kind of she has darkness in her as well
and I think he sees that and and she
sees that in him and maybe sees in him
this the parts of herself she's
repressing and so I think there is a an
untapped darkness of cami that we
potentially will be seeing semeth and
and i think at the same time Klaus sees
that darkness in her and sees someone
highly intelligent who is vulnerable and
human and fragile and yet sees him with
sympathetic eyes and looks at him not as
a monster but as a complex soul and
that's something that he doesn't
necessarily get all the time and doesn't
necessarily maybe think he deserves
completely so there's some attraction
there on there's no there's silence in
the audience no one like that let's talk
about something that they will like or I
mean it'll make you guys sad apologies
in advance but I feel like this season
more than last season and even more than
like young the Vampire Diaries I feel
like you guys just were so ruthless and
killed so many fan favorite characters
who we we all miss so much were there
any I mean I can I can list a few of
them if you want you know it Aiden
Cole I'm actually gonna stop this and
them making me sad
take us into the writers room like what
what which death was sort of boost to
blame is whatever asking who swim and
you know who were there any sort of
deaths that you guys really fought over
and then typical day we're sitting in
there talking about how much we love our
actors and our cast is phenomenal or
just kind of chilling out and then the
Angel of Death walks in and says I feel
like killing off so and so and then we
we figure that out they have a big room
that wheel with you live all day and
yeah I know how to spin it I say we did
we need a good death this time or a good
death it's time for somebody to go
Hayden sorry dude you're good
no honestly it's funny because this year
you know we had just remote mystical
point of view it's you know Daniel
Sharman who was so wonderful as coal
[Applause]
Beyond got a job or something like you
know we had to deal with the logistics
of actors like getting other different
opportunities or chasing you know their
dreams in like Saskatchewan and and and
then the Middle East and God knows where
which the thought of actors on our show
choose to do go chase those dreams but
but really for me like it's like the
best step is the death that you don't
want to do you know it's the death that
it's you know it took Kevin two years to
convince me to kill aunt Jenna you know
and I'm Vampire Diaries like I was so
determined not to ever kill and Jenna
and then finally one day like somebody
pitched it in a way and I went oh that's
terrible I love it you know so it's um
it's it's the deaths that you that make
you up hurt inside and I think Aidan
certainly was was one of those for us
mentioned I going back to Cole who we
mentioned I know you know we almost got
him back in the finale and then we
didn't I think some of you here are to
blame for that little switch up but what
are the odds that we're gonna see him
again and in which body would we see him
and
admittedly like a little a little
confused about how the body the body
swapping works well no we're gonna see
Cole the character Cole as played by
Nathaniel buzolic yeah in flashbacks
early in the season we're gonna kind of
get a you know glimpse at the whole
original family about ten years after
they were turned and see what their life
is like so as they've been struggling to
like adapt to this new part of
themselves and and and we we may even if
if we're lucky see a little glimpse of
him as well yeah I think Davina still
wants cold back and and she has a lot of
power with these witches so we'll have
to explore what her perspective is there
and then Freya still has Finn in an
amulet and we know that Vincent's body
is a decent vehicle for that soul so
will we see Yusuf playing two different
roles this season he does it so well
[Applause]
nice building applause I like that a lot
you sit all the way down there you are
at least on this panel right now the
newest cast member so how's it been for
you to kind of join and this is your
first comic-con no this is my first kind
of Akane this guy comic-con it's been a
humbling experience I had no idea that I
was going to be sitting in the
conference with as many people here and
just the love and the energy that I get
from the supporters of the show that we
all get from the supporters that this
show has been like nothing else I've
experienced so I'm so appreciative to be
here for this yeah I love you guys so
much thank you
how good is the oh now show how good at
youth and of course he's gonna be kind
of a sort of a mentor figure to Davina
do you know or have any idea kind of how
that's gonna gonna work I know she
doesn't really she doesn't really want
someone telling her what to do yeah
ideas that you can bring to fruition on
her own but I think this season we're
gonna see events and try to be a mentor
mentor for her whether or not she's
accepting of the idea what remains to be
seen we'll see of course well Danielle I
feel like of everybody up here you're
definitely one of the people whose
character has kind of changed the most
over the the two seasons I think you
were this you know this little witch
that was like kept up in an attic and I
heard this like badass region it was
just like making threats
how is that kind of that sort of growth
been for you as like as an actress you
know I think as well as as an actor I I
love it I mean it's what you really want
it's I've gotten to experience so many
different arcs and I've really gotten to
grow with the character and you see her
at the very beginning of season one
she's scared and she's people are after
her and she's locked in an attic and
then now it's he's leading people and
she's strong and it's such a cool thing
to be able to play such a character
that's gone through so much and then I
guess it's there's nothing more I could
have asked for it's it's fantastic yeah
and I know you know everybody loved at
the relationship between Davina and cool
I think that's it Nathaniel even posted
a picture on Twitter July 4th anything
was so you guys definitely were not
filming but it was I think got a hashtag
Covina he knows exactly what he's doing
[Music]
the goal we did not see you with how do
you kind of feel about who wants to see
Oliver back
[Music]
you know we loved watching two potato
Sharman are do you feel like Davina
could handle another love interest or
she fully kind of devoted to getting
coal back and forsaking all others you
know I think I think coal definitely had
a special place in her heart and I think
she'll always really care about him but
I think I think I think she's tried to
bring him back so many times and I think
she's not I don't know I don't think
she's gonna stop I mean I think about it
depends on what the writers end up
wanting to do but no I think I think
he's been really important or he's the
first person who really understood her
and I think she's seen him out a special
connection which is why they were able
to do so much with their magic yeah and
then talking about failed relationships
I feel like we have to talk to Charles
Michael Davis over there because you
have a way we talk about my personal
life nothing here and every time I saw
many talk shows I'm talking about Marcel
oh we've seen him with with quite a few
ladies Rebecca being the the most reason
and I feel like now she's gone she's
singles coming back well she's somewhere
out there yeah I hope she comes back
whatever body I don't care I like both
models you say that now and then she
chat you know I like where this is going
I'll be playing her in a sort of Monty
Python ask if we can't get Judi Dench
there I want you second choice yeah and
in talking about relationships you know
it's not just about romantic
relationships I think we all love kind
of the female characters when they can
all get together and just
have there they're nice moments there
have been too many nice moments lately
hadn't been kinda crazy in New Orleans
but can you can you kind of assurance
you know friendly moments between the
girls the season none no I'm not
actually you know there's a there's a
good faction of writers in our writers
room who really believe that the female
relationships and friendships are as
strong and as important to the show as
the supernatural staff and as as the
bromance and all that and the romance
and they fight really hard to find ways
to put characters together like like
Haley and who like we drink wine with
and hang out with now we figure out ways
to you know to develop those bonds it's
also fun it's lighter it's a lighter
tone or lighter energy which the show
needs every now and then to kind of
brighten and sparkle it up a little bit
Leah on the train yesterday was pitching
to one of our great writers Karina and
she goes hey there's a great idea it's
like Haley and kami and they're there on
the couch and they were in their sweat
pants and they're drinking wine I want
to do it like always we're so good at it
I would totally watch that show for the
record just show so it's there now you
guys are moving to a new night this fall
I'm sure you guys are excited about that
Thursday nights after the Vampire
Diaries
I would I would kind of kick myself if I
didn't to take the opportunity to ask if
you guys are potentially think about you
know any crossover situations I think
Michael Knight incidentally I thought
what you were gonna say is now that
you're on at 9 o'clock where things are
gonna get a little bit a little bit more
adult well that's you are then how much
more adult can they go I think they're
gonna get many adults
some people are gonna show up from the
past or potential sexy time you're
dodging questions look at that look at
that well the truth about crossovers is
[Laughter]
I have to give context to this because
earlier today somebody asked Andy asked
the question and I said to all of
America shall repeat I love crossovers
nerd if he won't do him and which is a
joke of course but he's been mad at me
all day
so this was your forum to guitar I think
this way I said this about crossovers
once that like a you know I'm writer and
producer on the originals I have my
sandbox of cast and characters who I can
play with and that's who I am focused on
all the time and I love those cast
characters I get very defensive about
them and what's going on with them and I
often feel sometimes for serialized
shows like ours which are heavily
serialized as opposed to something like
era and flash where they could team up
and fight a criminal and then be done
fighting that criminal and move on I
feel like what would happen if we did a
crossover is there would be a crossover
there would be a lot of backstory
there'd be a lot of catch-up and then
the characters would have to part ways
again and at the moment that they parted
ways again I think people would be
disappointed and angry all over again so
I fear that no matter what we do with a
crossover it wouldn't kind of live up to
the expectations the high expectations
that some people have so I focus on our
show and wait for my fearless leader to
tell me actually Mike I have the Vampire
Diaries and the originals and we're
going to do a crossover with both of
them and we're gonna bring in the people
from containment to God now we're gonna
go to audience questions I in just a
little bit but first I want to do
something fun I know it's not the
holidays and I know we don't have a like
a big-ass bonfire in front of us
but I thought it'd be kind of fun if
everybody kind of thinks about which
they would like for their character in
the future and you can just throw it in
the imaginary bonfire well I'm a human
so I just want to stay alive
wishes for everybody but I don't get to
have yeah I feel like Michael and Julie
giving it's like that's like Baskin
Puccini what is it
I do wish by the way Lena's you wish for
Julie that that supernatural Judge Judy
becomes her next spin-off and exploding
ovaries as the titles and your Billie's
next memoir I think I wish hailey would
be that hope can live a normal happy
existence I think that's very sweet
[Music]
I mean other than wishing that his
girlfriend's would not be incinerated by
not letting no one go easily so I would
wish for him oh man I wish for him I
actually I'm actually wishing for
something dark like I sort of would wish
for a great division between the
brothers before reconciliation is gonna
be I want I'm I was just realized to
where more racing jacket
that's what that is it sorry I took you
misread that I I wish everyone would
just do what Klaus says because he knows
what he's doing it's for the greater
good
come on get on board with his plans
everything will be all right in me and
not everyone will be all right in the
end but everything will be right right I
[Music]
just destroyed wishes so I should look
like your wish I wish Marcel would cross
over the cross I wish them all of your
cleavage get some dollar bills see
someone trying to make some money out
here yeah I have a 20 what can we get
really good 20 break it up break it up
break down your ones and let's make it
rain I can make a drizzle one if I throw
loose changing you're gonna make it hail
[Laughter]
next subject
Davina is a witch and I I think I think
it'd be really cool if she could fly so
whether it's a broomstick
I still think it'd be really cool so I'm
gonna say that's Akula mine's pretty
selfish I hate shaving so I wish we
could work something in so he can grow
like a huge
no no I changed my mind I want
superpowers as well three wonderful
retractable adamantium claws for me
please I want to fly I want to see the I
want to see these guys fly I want them
to charging up walls and we don't know
the budget I wanted ours are you or does
he more vampire recent why am i wishing
again yeah us can make as many witches
as you want this is your made-up
tradition it's raining wishes onions
raining here it is it's raining
everybody sucks we had an answer and
nobody did it but me in jail umbrella
umbrella awesome art what's odd turn it
over to some body Julie oh hi hi my name
is Julia and first I'd like to say that
I love you all especially Joseph Morgan
from Danielle Campbell occurred there
Daniel L Campbell and it's if you were
able to play another role who would you
want to play on our show or just in
general yeah on originals
I think I would choose Haley the hybrid
female she's a pretty cool character i
want to play anybody else i want to play
a larger fire absolutely had to I would
play Oliver because I I just think he
needs to be brought back to the show and
[Music]
hashtag say Bali bring him back again I
would play Elijah because I think I look
damn good in a suit I know it's
distracting for you my body I cannot
concentrate I refuse to continue I would
play Genevieve I thought she was a
really cool character yes she's a lot of
fun to work with yeah yeah nice um Jenna
be a fans in the house um yeah I think I
might utilize you too I think that's a
really cool character both quietly
believe they can bring more to the role
that's what they're saying
yeah not quietly this saying it to an
audience of like 3,000
only because of what you've done with my
name's Marissa first I want to say
Daniel I watched saving hope and your
death killed me I'm so sorry that you
died so my question is for Julie and
Michael um I was wondering there's so
much violence on the show and so much
adult stuff and I was wondering if the
network or the studio has ever told you
no you can't do that oh oh we have a
story about that don't we Leah yes
things that that we did that here's the
thing about about broadcast television
is apparently you can decapitate someone
you can drive a knife into a vampire
skull you can rip out their heart you
can shove a pencil up their nose you can
stab them a million times with glass but
when simulating a sex scene if there's
any movement at all that one would
define as fasting no thrusting pull back
on the thrusting no emotion that
originates from the
[Applause]
it's difficult because I don't remember
thrusting actually being in the script
so that was something that the actors
chose creative choice we we've got
Charles you would do the same thing
Joseph there was some excellent
spectacular simulated you know thrusting
in the in the scene that was cut her
broadcast standards well I think in the
same episode like seventeen people got
brutally massacred so you know it is
what it is and it was some of our best
thrusting and uh candidate I hope it
makes a special feature Charles called
Leah for some extra rehearsal beforehand
is for Joseph and Daniel Gillies so
Klaus has been really focused on like
ruling New Orleans so you could rule
your own kingdom where would it be and
why New York City it's the best city in
the world - I'm an unlovable
I mean London would be London in like
some penthouse overlooking the thirty
puppeteering yeah great question thank
you let's move the show that's it
hi I'm uh Scylla I know that between you
there's been a myriad of different
supernatural creatures Phoebe I think
you've been a werewolf or witch a
mermaid in a real way in real life what
would you want to be well I always say
witches because witches don't have to
turn on the full moon and they don't
have to be like plagued by a vampire
they're the demons of vampires they can
just have all the power and really cute
outfits and if I can look more like
Danielle Campbell I'll take it
what you can i I don't want to choose I
like being able to get into the shoes of
all of them this is a lot of fun to be
anything as a writer legs life is better
under the seat my man my man I'm no I
I'm pretty curvy so it's a invisibility
now I'm happy where I am
you know hybrid hybrid it's definitely
not invisibility there you go
no definitely I'm happy where I am you
know I when I join the show I was I
thought I was only gonna be a vampire I
was thrilled to be half I'm sticking to
my canvas
I like being the token human and I'm
just gonna like stay there and created
more mermen season 3 season of the
moment you better look come in the water
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the question what's going on man which
is like what is going on right now how
do I feel about h2o child is a part of
me as a man made in East dressing room
yeah yeah no it sits on top of my
frigerator I'm still waiting to get it
autograph like please please sign that
picture make my day that I could finally
frame it wait what's your question
what's supernatural creature would you
be if you could if you could choose
anything Oh a fire-breathing dragon or a
unicorn that's my answer donkey from
Shrek okay I think we've gone way of
course here anybody here ever wants to
be Adventures of Pete and Pete yeah you
guys remember mister swirl who
disappeared every year summer left on
the floor is there anyone you would
dress up as Daniel Gillies let me borrow
that jacket Obama fat but probably done
your gibbie's
bobo gillies
[Laughter]
that's good thank you thank you
let's listen hi I'm Tiana I just want to
say you're all brilliant actors and this
is the only show it's like I have the
test the next day i watch is to study my
test so my questions for Joseph who's
whose calls this favorite sibling and
why
Wow look you know Klaus favorite not my
favorite you understand
Klaus is favorite I think is Rebecca is
most protective Allah and Elijah always
a lie just not Elijah not Elijah Rebekah
because he is the most protective over
her she's been as you know is that was
this very he I think he feels more sort
of parental towards her so yeah yeah
definitely definitely not he's my
personal favorite that's story after
Dean visibility in the dressing room
[Laughter]
inspects listen hi I'm Haley and I
wanted to know how you guys would want
to die in this show that's so good
that's like the best question yeah no
did she give me write this down
I know how I want to go out in a blaze
of glory filled by Elijah in a giant
sword fight that's that's the great
answer
maybe it could be a double sort of like
you stab me in the heart but I stabbed
you in this I'd want to be murdered by
Klaus okay I think I want to be finally
murdered by by Klaus or like a mercy
killing by Hayley
can I say [ __ ] idiot I did it again
I'm setting a new promise it will not
say good Russ story with that I'm a new
father twos disgraceful
[Laughter]
I think I've said enough yeah we are now
on at 9 p.m. I would say I would want to
die with vampire blood in my system I
want to go out like even Evel Knievel on
a motorcycle just flying off a ramp I
don't know why how we're gonna work that
in but that's how I want to go
Davina's died once already
I would like to die a second time read
your mind young lady ok I'm Donna yes oh
[ __ ] I was hoping you guys um I think it
would be really cool if if Davina took
me out she went hella dark and took me
out that'd be funny
it'd be fun don't get any ideas
Joey do you have an answer
yeah no I have I have my I have the list
yeah lucky way this thing it's ugly
sad you I want to go out like Papa Tunde
I want it to be my choice my time and
then I want to infuse my soul into a
blade that causes suffering to all my
enemies Hedegaard is really dark thank
you for the question hi I'm maze and I
just wanted to ask is there anything
that will be happening romantically
between Klaus and Camille you get you
answer this I mean I don't know I don't
know I think that you know in the
beginning when we when we were putting
the show together the part of Cammie was
listed as a romantic interest but mouse
and possibly myself I think it's evolved
beyond that now she's more like his
therapist
although yeah they do have those hey
come on they do have those um those
moments couch time those you know those
sort of fleeting glances or whatever so
yeah I don't know I don't know we've
certainly been building it for a long
time so maybe yeah why did you walk away
like in that scene the season finale
like we were so close why did I because
I was reading my script and her line is
the clouds walks away and so I thought
I'm going I think it's time for one more
question
hi my name is Melissa and this is Lila a
big h2o fan
and unfortunately our question on which
creature you would prefer to be has been
taken glad to hear that some of you
prefer to be mermaid but my question is
for Daniel and oh yes I'm talking to you
it's gonna be bad bad mr. wickham I
would like to know if you would ever
consider going back to Bollywood or
going back to Jane Austen I'd love to go
back to both but I'm pretty occupied
right now between being a father and and
doing this show but yes I would love to
do both
I love particularly loved traveling
through India it was it was sort of one
of the most heartbreaking and beautiful
things I've ever experienced but yeah I
would love to go back to both things and
and to do it to do Jane Austen would be
what it would be amazing and I know this
about you thank you well thank you guys
so much for coming out
[Applause]
you